hi everyone in California it's Kim
kardashian-west
and I just wanted to talk to you and
molest west northwest just crashed Kim
Kardashian's PSA about social distancing
and it's the kind of comedy we all need
right now hi everyone in California it's
Kim kardashian-west and I just wanted to
talk to you and Northwest have a serious
conversation with you guys about social
distancing I know it's California we've
got the most beautiful weather but we
have to start to train ourselves you
went outside in your backyard and that's
totally fine
on Monday California governor Gavin
Newsom shared a recorded public service
announcement from Kim encouraging fans
to stay home okay so guys we just want
you to social distance there's so many
fun amazing projects you can do you can
spend time with your kids and have so
much fun trust me I want to get out more
than you know preach Kim preach I know
that give me like two seconds seriously
the whole thing is super freakin
relatable because Kim's six-year-old
daughter made it hard a F to get the job
done
really important to also do mental
health checks on your friends with your
loved ones
that's ass though she's like a mini
Kanye I'm just extremely happy can you
tell by my face honestly staying at home
is saving lives
and that's what we're all trying to do
here all right that's it
stay stay but this isn't the first time
North has barged in on her famous mama
mid work sash can you do it in the other
room in the middle of something I don't
want to get this all wet speedy in whose
warranty kneeing with her hubby and
their four kids at home amid the corona
virus pandemic tried to film a makeup
tutorial last week and well it didn't go
great I'm hiding in the guest room
because Mike
it will not leave me alone hiding from
your kids in the bathroom is a mood
north can I please just do my little
tutorial uh-huh it's all I want to do is
one little fun thing for myself parents
I see you I respect you and I am sending
you all some big virtual hugs so that
was a quick k'kaw beauty mostly using
kicking joking beauty products glam in
my guest room quarantine glam just to go
to the kitchen to get harassed by my
kids and on how to do their homework
[Music]
[Music]